la cooperación espacial continúa o por
lo menos así se demuestra tras la
llegada de tres cosmonautas a la
estación espacial internacional
dos de sus connacionales y rusos tres
estadounidenses y un alemán que ya
prestaban servicio en el módulo espacial
los recibieron y es que a pesar de las
tensiones que se viven en tierra el
hecho demuestra que las relaciones en el
espacio no están rotas
bueno es cierto que tengamos nuestros
problemas con el presidente putin
pero esto es tierra firme una vez que
llegas al espacio el programa espacial
civil es lo más profesional posible los
cosmonautas y los astronautas y espero
que esto continúe entre las penalidades
impuestas a rusia por su invasión a
ucrania eeuu ordenó varias restricciones
a la exportación de tecnología contra
moscú para degradar la industria
aeroespacial rusa la respuesta por parte
del jefe de la agencia espacial rusa fue
el anuncio de medidas recíprocas y días
después sugirió el destino de la
estación internacional si bloquean la
cooperación con nosotros quien salvará a
la estación espacial internacional de
una salida de órbita descontrolada y de
su caída en eeuu o europa a pesar de las
amenazas la nasa dice estar tranquila
hacia el dmitri rogózin habla sin pensar
de vez en cuando pero al final del día
ha trabajado con nosotros sin embargo
expertos ven una posible ruptura con
otros aspectos en cuenta
es posible imaginar una ruptura con
rusia que pondría en peligro la estación
espacial
pero eso sería el nivel de una caída de
las relaciones diplomáticas sería un
último recurso y realmente no veo que
eso suceda a menos de que haya una
confrontación militar más amplia en este
contexto se supo que esta semana la
agencia espacial europea esa suspendió
el lanzamiento del primer rover
planetario del 'viejo continente' en
colaboración con los cosmos como
consecuencia de la guerra rusa